aleksander immortality is a scholar who
really has changed the terms of the
debate about war on the street in the
economy he's moved us from trying to
defend oral history on the terms of
positivist historians to making a really
powerful and transformative argument
that oral history sources are compelling
and meaningful on their own terms and in
ways that are similar to and different
from other kinds of primary sources but
certainly not secondary to and I've had
the pleasure of teaching with Sondra and
our annual Summer Institute for over a
decade now on and off and so we're very
happy to welcome him back to Columbia
Sandra's work and as far as I've seen is
the work of an oral historian that's
most likely to permeate outside of the
field of oral history so it's an
anthropology professor assigns a week on
oral history they're going to assign
Saunders work I've been for history
professor assigns we've got on or off
the street they're given a science
thunderous work he's ready didn't
folklore in literature really across the
disciplines and he's been a very
powerful ambassador for our way of
thinking and so more formally he taught
American literature at the University of
Romans for 2012 he's the founder of the
circular Bozzio for the critical study
of people's cultures and the author of
several oral history books which I
expect many of you are familiar with
including the definite solution is doing
other stories the order has been carried
out and they say
County most recently so thank you so
much sundar for coming here and share
your work with us and I'll turn it over
to you thank you for having me and thank
you for for coming and I've been coming
to the oral history Institute at Target
for Oh 20 years now
so this is coming home I had a major
problem last year when they moved the
same the Institute from one place to the
other because it wasn't that prudent for
my neighbor to rearrange all my sense of
space in the city so it's wonderful to
be back and to be back for a longer
period and for the first time in my life
to be teaching oral history teach you
something else all the time and so it's
really it's really wonderful thank you
for this opportunity now what I'm going
to talk about it's almost incidental to
do my work and in fact it has to do with
learning from from my mistakes learning
from my universe and it has to do with
the fact that icons I'm entirely
self-taught person in this field and had
no formal training or anything so that
all that I learned that all that I
taught them
has always come from trial and error
from from thinking about what I had done
right and what I had done wrong so this
is one thing that I've learned from
something that I did wrong and it has to
do as the title of the talk is with
stories that I heard but I would not
listen to because we keep talking I I've
been talking for years about oral
history as an art of listening and and
in our society where we all claim the
right to speak the fact that we all we
all want to find our voice but very few
of us listened and we keep talking about
here says all of history is one of those
things that give a hearing to people and
so the patience in listening they being
receptive these arts they make tools of
anybody who's working with oral sources
podcasting oral history but it was a
comedy for everywhere in any field where
the words of someone else become the
foundation of what you do with what you
learn and your thoughts
however since we've more or less
for coral s human beans we don't listen
all the time with the same intensity and
we do not listen to everything with the
same we'll pay attention to everything
honestly part of this is because the
oral history encounter is also it's
basically an encounter between two
agendas one agenda is yours why are you
doing this interview so I'm this person
because it were cool mindset for the
county because you was it them distance
in Rome because he was a steelworker in
Germany because it was a student
activist in Rome
so definitely ma gender is about to know
more about the life of somebody even
though my practice has been to look to
know very much about the person before I
talk to them because they want the story
to be my first source of information yet
if I'm doing a project on the
steelworkers intending I'm interested in
steelworks and working class and work
and labor ends on on the other hand the
person you talked to
the interviewee has an agenda as well
and she has things that she wants to
talk about that are not part of your
agenda and sometimes these things will
be important to you so it will open up
whole new vistas sometimes they want and
you know one of us one of the things
that opened up in trying to visit us to
be one I started doing this project the
struggles in the steelworks in therapy
from 1949 to 1953 and they in the first
interview I did I interviewed this
worker a former worker could be fired in
1953 and it's on the story as well and
so forth what it was like to be in
factoring where it came from what he did
afterwards then his wife grabbed the
microphone which is the opposite of
usually happens
let's see so she grabs the microphone
and she says you know my
great-grandfather on his wedding day
he took his bride home he said angrily
buys lunch doctor in an honest way to
buy lunch
he ran into giuseppe garibaldi on
national liberator who was marching
south to liberate italy so he joined
Caliban they never came home until four
years later after he's liberated Italy
so the basic question was what do I do
with this do I you know one of my
mother's is especially if you come from
literature you you don't throw away that
story's just because it's not just
because it's not true but just because
it's not part of your agenda have you
change your agenda because you heard the
story and so the book that was supposed
to be 1949 and 1953 ended up being 1831
to 1985 this is a case where you know
the encounter of the two agendas meant
that yours was being changed and it's a
form of serendipity in fact you find
things that you were looking for and
then we started looking for them in fact
after that is done asking people if they
had ancestors in in the kind of poverty
in liberation but then a surprising
number of people
and they had incredible stories
incredible also because they were Park
affected a lot of meaning of the meaning
of nature of our national liberation
came from that from sometimes you have
stories that you just don't think will
be of interest digressions and
and of course since good manners is the
basic interviewing technique if somebody
goes into a whole story in direction
that you are not interested and you will
bear with it and when it's over
reasonably of course and which means
that you know this is sort of the price
you pay for the basic thing which they
interview is about because people are
giving you giving us their knowledge
they're getting also giving us coffee
and also the time what we're giving them
is time these are people that nobody
ever listens to more or less a lot of
them so here comes this guy who's this
woman who is more or less paid for
listening to them and so we just open up
that disgorge everything you want
it says it's like City for your portrait
in a way and yeah so you have to give
them time to table but they would they
need to talk about it and so when I was
and sometimes they don't realize that
what they're telling you is at least as
important or more important than what
you were looking for that's another
story
I've been telling over and over again
when I was interviewing this lady and
I'll be talking about this lady later
Josephine Emilio see about her brother
who had been in the underground
communist organization nineteen thirties
and she it was a rifle with her to talk
about it but what she really wanted to
talk about was her love story with a
fascist who then she stated he was
engaged to for seven years and then he
dropped her and broke the engagement
and she insisted in telling and
retelling the story until I finally gave
in you know and the result is there are
two lines in his book about her process
and there's a chapter about her because
in the end if you're looking for what we
look for the history of daily life the
history of subjective in the history of
feelings then this complicated love
story is tells you a lot more about
fascism than
the activists the underground activism
of her brother so sometimes you just
realize that that thank you
sometimes you don't and I will have to
amend my earlier statement that I had no
formal training when I was given my
first tape recorder you were cost me
like two months I had one technical
teaching from Franco cordula
who was a fantastic feel Bergman he said
never put the money on the same table as
you put recorded because it will pick up
the voice of the engines that that no
longer applies for electronic to digital
but it still remains as some kind of
in reaction that it cannot place uh
michael ii teaching was Jamie Mosley
Johnny bossy my mentor and and what he
told me was as he handed me the Taser
never turned it off which was a hard
thing to learn because of course L was
paying for manual tape and tape was a
defensive back there but
why don't you turn it off basically for
two reasons and one is it's absolutely
rude to signal to the person you're
interviewing
I thought interesting what you're
talking about are now safe some take of
batteries and the other is you will
never you never know if what is not
interesting to you now may turn out to
be interesting in 10 years which is what
we have archives for incidentally so and
so this is what actually happened that I
barely listened to things that seemed to
me not to fit my agenda which was
working-class history of an industrial
heart and because it was doing you know
somebody earlier asked me what was the
most difficult challenge in my own
history work and I answer having to
transcribe everything by myself so in
order to save some of the work there
were some sort that I thought they do
not fit my project I was just not
transcribe them and and there were two
types of stories one was the stories we
heard over and over again from men about
major service war and it was a mistake a
methodological ever to think they did
not they did not fit my agenda
I skipped them because he said well
these are not specifically definitely
narratives so I'm not interested in fact
I ended up writing a book in which
nobody from their nearest serves in the
middle the other stories that I skipped
was when we even went into these long
narratives about having a relative a lot
when in the hospital and assisting not
so much and stories about they being in
the hospital but being in a hospital
with a husband with a child and I get
those
I mean these stories last week before I
came just what they be a couple days
before with it I was talking to him and
a friend can suddenly she went into a
long narrative being when their
three-year-old child was in the hospital
and while she how they treated him and
they gave him the wrong medicine because
they didn't know they didn't know his
history and how she had to correct the
doctors and so I had dozens of stories
like this
and I did not when I was doing the
technique project transparently and they
never gave Don a second thought
until one day for some reason I asked
myself the question okay these are the
two stories that I skipped do they have
something in common and one of the
reasons I was able to ask myself this
question was that I had just
participated in a conference on the
memory of World War one they're now
being flooded hundred years since Italy
entered but we always had those because
World War one was
there was a huge turning point in the
history of the country in the in the
experience we knew a lot more the World
War two
even though there are lots of narratives
and historian Maggie Bailey gave a paper
in which he said were just but the whole
war and bitter experience has a lot of
implications another way you leave home
especially World War one Italy had been
a unified country for forty-five years
eight years people from Sicily couldn't
talk to people from
they only beat the body being able to
talk to each other since renovations
that unified the language they didn't
even know they weren't the same kind of
tracing so they're you know they
couldn't Centrify the other end of the
nation so they finally discover number
one you know the world outside they
leave home and number two here dealing
with the state suddenly and the state
means an institution
it means the army and the army means
hierarchy
it means technology and the for swarm is
life and death so the war narrative was
was about all these things was about
Google people learning to deal with
machines weather was machine guns but
people who have been village pound gang
homes in a world war and and people who
had been in often in estill semi-feudal
environment discovering the complicated
structures of the modern state as
represented by the
and then it occurred to me that in a way
this is what the stories the hospital
Women's Hospital stories were about
leaving the altar or the other
generations of women were very much stay
at home in fact another set of
narratives about women finding a space
outside the home had to do with church
work because it was okay for them to
leave home to go to church or it was
necessary but to leave home because her
husband was in a hospital
so yeah leaving home and dealing with an
institution the hospital with its
hierarchies with its technology with
this language and again dealing with
life and death then we're just very
interesting a lot of men would go into a
technical language about weapons about
women have to learn anybody that has
been vessel during a whole other
language my favorite it is a way in
which women from Harlan County
familiarize technical terms medicine
like finding worse disease in Kentucky
becomes our timers which i think is
wonderful and a lot of these complicated
words that become family arise because
you have to learn a new language and
there's one type of narrative which is
shared it's part of a future narrative
model but it's almost inevitable in any
narrative of the military and in any in
this is the story of facing up to the
hierarchy and telling the lieutenant
they doesn't know how the ground is laid
and telling the head doctor that gets no
medicine your child needs and that he
was a common person no more than the big
one of the most dramatic stories trying
to tell the officers that they're doing
things wrong is a story the north
eastern front
and words were one was a war in which
men were sent to the slaughter with
loans there's this one that says to
conquer a piece of ground how many
brothers a big deal and so there's this
unit and the lieutenant says tomorrow we
will attack the enemies in this industry
now four of the men are from the place
and they say no we can't do it they're
that way because because that's the way
the ground is laid we would be exposed
we should do it the other way
the lieutenant refuses to accept the
fact that they may know more about it he
does so in the end he gets them all
executed for mutiny and they happen to
be the only four people accused of
desertion in front of the enemy who have
a monument so this is the type of
narratives you hear may be less dramatic
in but it comes and again the story of
my friend this is the doctor didn't know
that the dosage of medicine was given to
my baby
to my child was wrong because he needed
the difficulty and I know you needed a
different dosage because I read the
papers I know what was happening to him
and so I would like to read and comment
one such story and this is mrs. Debbie
Spicer miss Debbie Spicer was a coal
miners wife living in a former coal camp
in Harlan County and she is talking
about the last days of her fortunately
by the time she told me the story I knew
enough not to not just get it in
transcribe we took him to the hospital
and they checked a lot of things but one
of the key words here is they they're
nameless the hierarchy effect later on
she says then bring me to doctor you
didn't call dr. Newman you've been Kusum
own doctor and who probably knows more
anyway they just had him on the tables
for a long time and didn't do anything
and he had trouble with the spouse she
was treating him with mineral water and
they did not know about it they didn't
know and they were giving the wrong
stuff to bring so his bowels was I said
I go get yourself to Janice at Kmart
they just got her some waters between
the nurses and me they just spread up
some water under the table and I washed
it cleans it up and spread some towels
over him so he wouldn't get too cold
until I came back to this began
and when I came back I couldn't speak
Amazon I put his pajamas on no he didn't
because one of the things that happen
here is Miss Maggiore and a whole
extraordinary narrative about this she
was married to this very very fascist
husband in the nineteen thirties who she
doesn't say Phoebe her own but
absolutely authoritarian and something
he gets sick any listen to the hospital
and now she's power amuse behind she's
handing him he he is like a baby in his
hands there's a reversal of power in
this narrative which does not occur as
often in the military narratives this
these authoritarian husbands and fathers
who become babies I wash them dreams
about of course she knows how to do it
because you're watching conduct babies
on her life I work to clean them up and
spread some towels over him so she also
protects his sense of decency his
nakedness till I came back to this
pajamas and then I came back
interesting therefore these are very
cool people so where does she die now my
son came out they didn't have too many
people they didn't even give me a flask
when I came back with my niece she said
and she gonna have to see him and I said
no he's just wound so she went back in
and told the plenty
yeah incidentally I'm reading a novel
just I was reading this novel on the
train coming over I was reading this
novel through the train coming over this
Italian writer who's supposed to be
popular here as well Elena Ferrante and
there's a whole episode about her mother
being in the hospital and the family she
internal feuding in the family about who
is going to take charge of her and also
claiming that the doctor stopped knowing
after having a better doctor come over
yeah so it's it's a common everyday
narrative and she's talking about that
then she says no she went back had told
that play these nameless them by the
time we got home his bowels were just
awful
they wouldn't call his doctor they
didn't call doctor you back doctor you
think is a proper doctor was
Harlan County and he would have known
what this man needed he would have known
that this man had problems with his
stomach which the big doctors at the the
big University Hospital in Lexington
no one didn't care about well I don't
know what to do
I said North I don't know what to do my
grandson said take it to parable so we
got an ambulance and went there it was
about 11 we had never lived there before
never met no doctors never met no nurses
I didn't know how I was going to face it
so here comes a bright side we got there
they just took me in have you been here
before have you got a doctor I said no
I've never been here before it just took
us in and they gave us 24-hour service
what time they stayed Sunday night 11:30
at 12 o clock and he died Tuesday
morning at 12 o clock so she's not
attacking the hospital per se but she is
talking about differences she's talking
about the sense of personality in the
big institution is a big academic
institution and the closer care you get
closer to home and and also and this is
say the same narrative I had from
Sudi cruising Barry some of you may have
seen the film Harlan County USA and SUNY
gruesome Barry's one of the feelings of
that feeling and she said she has the
same type of narrative about her husband
being ill and taking him to the hospital
and in this case the local hospital is
as if personal and distant as a big
Hospital in Lexington in the Debbie
Spicer's narrative but but then she has
another complication there and the
complication is the Union Hospital card
so they're not only having to deal with
the hospital they're having to deal with
the bureaucracy getting the loved one
attended and being able to afford okay
so she goes into this very complex
narrative about what the Union hospital
car covered and what it didn't cover and
wondered what her husband had that was
covered and what the husband had wasn't
covers and they flowed in to the
narrative of the great rebellion in her
in Eastern Kentucky from 1962 to 1964
when the Union took back the miners
hospital card so the story public
hospital
the hospital narrative generated the
Union narrative there and of course
they're all stories about life and death
there's a basic difference of course in
the case of war narratives you can die
it's your life you can die they can also
kill and a lot none of the narratives
about the war narratives are about
killing
in the case of the hospital stories
what's it's life and death but if
somebody's somebody else's life and not
yours and about maybe natural death or
just by institutions errors so
ultimately these stories are about
gender gender roles they're about gender
roles today challenge gender roles do
they confirm gender
no more narratives of course men are
supposed to be warriors however the
majority of stories you have about world
war one and almost all the songs that
are still in oral tradition our songs
against the war there's some in which
they refuse indeed they're very
ambivalent
they're very ambivalent because they all
these soldiers have been educated into
the relics of patriotism into the idea
that the enemy is evil is that the
enemies out there to kill them so it
starts out and also with the national
pride that's what they've been educated
on then what happened
to them is something else and one song
that we discovered recently begins with
here at the Battle of the battles the
battle begins we can hear the gun the
cannons roar and here we will prove the
prowess of the Italian nation next verse
the ground was covered with blood and
torn up bodies and they were crying for
help and we told them no use at all for
your mom your dying along so interesting
call from your mom again you know you're
becoming a son a child so these are very
ambivalent narratives the women's
hospital areas of course they confirm
the woman's fall as carriers in fact as
that's responsible for life and death
for for giving birth and for assisting
and and they all take place in the
framework of the family the woman is
there as a wife as a daughter as a
mother and she's more or less doing what
is what's expected of her on the other
hand what is expected of her implies a
may be temporary subversion of authority
which means which has to do with the way
you deal with your husband's or your
father's with with the child and of
course it's different but it has to do
with the fact that you're turning your
husband and your father or your father
into your baby again you're applying the
skills that you learned as a mother so
again this is not a subversive narrative
but it's a narrative that complicates
things that complicates the
relationships of gender within within
the family so this is more or less what
I learned and I've been going back to
the stage and finding that these stories
keep coming back that hardly any of the
women I attributed the elderly women
to give daily or if did not have a story
like this
Annie Napier a great friend and never
Charlotte who came here and taught at
the Institute a few years ago I mean
she's the one that taught me not the
word Alzheimer's disease because you had
to deal with that a lot and but her she
also had a very complicated narrative
about what her husband was was disabled
by an accident at work he was he drove a
coal truck and one day he was called in
in a belt line and it's our most men
gold anyway he was he was and what she's
talking what she talked about was how
special she was who she raised in he was
she said before the accident he was and
absolutely it was a stereotypical Harlan
County male latarian and Frank he he
fought
after the accident and after she dealt
with him and the way I knew him he
turned into one of the sweetest people I
ever knew
and it had to do with her taking over
and he become independent from from the
accident and then for the rest of their
lives
because he was getting disability but
she was the one that worked and brought
money so once again this was not a
subversion of gender roles but this was
a different articulation of gender roles
that began with an experience any also
had a harrowing narrative of fighting
the ignorance and the responsibility of
the doctors over the body of the patient
which in this case the patient was her
and she was giving birth and it was
number one here and the doctor said she
needs a caesarean this generator the war
with a fundamentalist parents and family
I know because you don't do that you
don't do surgery if you were old regular
deafness so she that first then
she's she's there giving birth to this
child and the doctor is drunk every
doctor is pregnant and something else
happens and and the birth SATs coming up
and they call another doctor and that's
this battle between the two doctors over
her body and finally you know then your
doctor says if you if you lose this
patient I'm gonna have your kicked out
oh and she finally nice I have the baby
so ultimately what what does this
teachers
No it teaches also something about the
relationship between what people think
of as history and what people think all
that biography because when you're doing
a long history and again the men who
talk about the war they know they're
talking about historical event all the
women who talk about the air raids or
the bombings they know they're talking
about history we were talking about this
what are they talking about or the
stories that I heard we meant having to
fend off sexual harassment widows having
to fend off sexual harassment in 1940s
and 50s they to them this is my history
because of course they're not educated
to think of history in terms of gender
history social history history of the
body history of sexuality but so they
offered with not volunteer this kind of
stories and we don't know enough plaster
there but no when they do and these
Hospital narratives are always volunteer
never occur to me to ask about it
because I didn't know what are they
talking about
they're talking about that the fact that
their lives matter that their lives
matter and whether this is history or
not I've got to talk about it because
that's the other great lesson but is it
because the interviews it's not about
anything it's not about the working past
it's not about the fact that the
interview as Bob uses and this is what
happened to me and this is the other big
thing this is not tested this is
narrative and testicle he tends to be
about something you've seen something is
witness in most latin languages witness
and testimony of the same word of
something out there narrative has to do
with your life and whether your life is
recognized as historically significant
or not it's your life and the fact that
somebody's there for whatever reason to
hear a conversation about your life also
in most cases what is the question I ask
in the initial question tell me about
your life
I was tell the story because and I will
tell the story and this story is
important because without breaking
gender roles yet I changed their record
and perhaps I learned a different sense
of who I was and how I stood in the
family neighborhood and also promised to
in the context of the state in the
context of science in the context of
Technology in the concepts of authority
I gained Authority there these are all
stories about gaming Authority Authority
in front of the doctors who do not know
that you're not supposed to give mineral
water to this man authority from your
husband with fabulousness in your hands
and authority in your own sense so
that's the basic lesson I got from from
initial state not turning the tape
recorder off or turning my attention off
and we all have
just give a span of attention sometimes
we should also train ourselves to keep
it high thank you